one of the chapters that really
intrigued me from your book was a red
flags chapter do you believe that the
biggest one out of all these is the
inability to acknowledge their issues
and work on improvement my advice to
guys is if you're going to invite a
woman into your life whether that's as a
girlfriend or a wife you vet for red
flags so that you didn't invite a
nightmare into your life there was a
sound bite somewhere and it's jack
nicholson talking to woman and a woman
you know runs up to him she's like how
do you know women so well sort of thing
and he goes well i think of a guy and
then i take away accountability and
reason does that mean women aren't
accountable or they don't have reason no
but they're more emotional than men you
know let's take something as the fat
acceptance movement this narrative is
coming from women not from men men
aren't saying you know that's body
shaming or why can't you accept me for
who i am it's always morbidly obese left
leaning women with short purple hair
saying that they're not different from
the skinny model that's on the billboard
you know posing for swimsuit
competitions or whatever things are
right and that's a lack of
accountability